i want to look at some fox news reaction
to what is taking place in the russia
ukraine border area particularly donetsk
and luhansk where russia has now invaded
slowly but they've they've invaded um
fox news immediately went to blame biden
and it's kind of i mean it's sort of
funny but it's not
i half jokingly tweeted yesterday
afternoon
before the invasion
how long until they say
trump never would have let putin invade
ukraine or are are they already saying
it and it actually happened very quickly
but was hilariously kind of spoiled by
fox news's own reporters here are some
examples hannity spent the vast majority
of his show last night um blaming joe
biden
and saying that this is biden's weakness
is what has allowed this to happen in
russia ukraine etc etc this ignores the
fact that trump was totally
under the thumb of putin seemed enamored
with putin as well as many other
authoritarians during his presidency
this ignores that circumstances have
been building for probably 20 years that
relate to what is maybe even more that
that are now take that relate to what's
taking place on the russia ukrainian
border but despite hannity spending much
of his show blaming joe biden when
reporter jennifer griffin pops up she
goes you know sean actually what's going
on predates this administration hannity
sort of upended by his own reporters
sean how we got to this point is a long
story and it predates the biden
administration it goes back and includes
mistakes made by every u.s president
since the soviet union fell apart which
putin has said was the worst
geopolitical catastrophe of the 20th
century uh oh well that's not the
narrative that sean hannity has been
pushing on his show even peter ducey uh
who some consider one of the doofiest
reporters out there
hannity was complaining oh joe biden
called the lid he's not doing anything
even ducey has to tell hannity actually
even though it's nighttime biden is
actively coordinating a response with
our allies and the reason that we have
not seen him yet is because they're
trying to get everybody on board and
he's been working the phone trying to
get a bunch of allies to sign on to a
statement with him something uh oh but
but sean hannity said biden's doing
nothing and he called the lid and this
is all his fault this is of course so
much bigger than biden but the response
similarly to when joe biden left
afghanistan the narrative is
biden is in the wrong biden is the cause
of problems biden is the reason we don't
have a solution and the very same people
who were saying
biden's gonna get us into wars and
biden's bad and trump would have been
better because trump kept us out of wars
those very same people are saying well
biden should have been more aggressive
to prevent this from happening so they
are going to go with this narrative no
matter what even a republican senator
ron johnson is doing the old blame biden
this was him last night uh but the fact
of the matter is there's not much we can
do right now uh what we should have done
is is maintain strength uh
you do achieve peaceful strength but
that's not just military strength it's
also economic strength and as i was
saying earlier just about every action
president biden has taken has weakened
america it's emboldened our enemies
they're very optimistic they're very
aggressive when they sense weakness
they're going to act so wait a second
the same peop this is a reminder guys to
think what are our principles and are we
standing by them the same people who
were saying we should be more friendly
with russia we should we should be
friends with putin we should be friends
with russia we we should be nice we
don't want war with russia now we're
saying biden's been too weak he hasn't
shown strength he hasn't deterred these
people should not even be part of the
conversation they are just horrible
people and they don't care about
anything other than criticizing
democrats there it's not they they add
nothing to the conversation we're going
to take a quick break and we'll be back
with more coverage of what's happening
in russia and ukraine